nicolas sarkozy a été condamné le 1er
mars 2021 dans l' affaire dite des
écoutes à trois ans d'emprisonnement
dont un an ferme pour corruption active
et trafic d'influencé sans surprise
l'ancien président de la république
compte faire appel pour se défendre
nicolas sarkozy utilise un argument en
remettant en cause notamment
l'impartialité de ses juges il est vrai
que l'impartialité de la justice est un
principe fondamental et qu'il est
protégé par la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme que la france a
ratifié et qu'elle a donc l'obligation
de faire respecter
nicolas sarkozy qui avait traité les
juges lorsqu'il était président de la
république de petits pois car ils se
ressemblent tous
même origine même formation disait-il se
plaindre et de ce que les juges
désormais est trouvé avec l' affaire des
écoutes un moyen de se venger et il est
vrai comme le dit nicolas sarkozy que
l'impartialité s'effondre dès que
l'accusé a la conviction personnelle que
le juge n'était pas impartial
l'apparence de partialité suffirait à
dire donc que le juge est partial
l'ancien président menace donc de saisir
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
pour faire reconnaître cette partialité
sauf qu'à regarder de plus près les
raisons que la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme retient habituellement
le cas sarkozy laisse peu de chance à
nicolas karr encore faut-il que cette
apparence de partialité soit confirmée
par un observateur objectif nous dit la
cour de ce point de vue il n'est pas sûr
que cet observateur aurait le même avis
que nicolas sarkozy si la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme suivait
le raisonnement de l'ancien président il
suffirait à n'importe quel accusé ou
prévenu d'insulter tout la magistrature
pour échapper à tout procès